we now turn to the Commission proposal
concerning a financial transactions tax
tax payers in the EU are right to expect
that financial institutions make fear
and substantial contribution to covering
the costs of the crisis led action
Whitburn limited new Atlanta Dijon
message address Syrian population he
sweat do about this institution kuru
sector mocha suited for Moses you know
to the sector finishes to inform
occasional contributor I was optioned
like this torva clemmy's on plus
docetaxel intellectual she knows Chanel
Iman satisfaction we have to be
realistic about and truthful to our
public's about who pays this tax there
is not a single banker in the world who
is going to pay this tax there are no
banks that are going to pay this tax the
people who pay this tax are pensioners
who have pensions and they have to pay
this tax there are taxpayers through
their governments I suggest we just put
this idea to bed there is nothing close
to unanimity in this council about it
the Danish government is a very strong
supporter of a global transaction tax
and hopefully these discussion could
make us be a more pressing ahead in the
international discussion about global
transaction scale tax I see no reason
why we should give up on on that my
deceit wasn't this notes random so we
need to reach a solution quickly the cds
this argument sinter few of our boys
miss Marietta and affiliate and that
some people say well we have win favor
which has to be also introduced globally
well that's just an excuse for doing
nothing and the idea by the way that the
United States or China all alone
singapore are going to contemplate this
in my lifetime i think is you know
fanciful frankly one day i disagree with
her George is much much younger than me
and I think that in my lifetime I will
see a financial transaction tax thank
you
I see that there's a strong feeling in
favor of having a quick resolution both
among those who want to see the
transactions tax come about quickly and
those who want to see it not come about
quickly